ich möchte euch was wollen wir noch vor
den zu verkaufen wir sehen was ich
gestern abend erlebt habe ja ich war ich
war auf einer veranstaltung eines
start-up-unternehmens ja hast du gesagt
ich bin in die höhle der löwen am
montagabend gibt es das immer wir sind
am markt über und gestern abend haben
wir eine art public viewing gemacht
30 40 leuten wo wir gemeinsam in die
sendung angeschaut haben und dann kam
irgendwann ja und ich muss euch sagen es
war ja diese zuversichtliche staat
abstimmung die haben gearbeitet bis zum
anschlag in den letzten sechs monaten
keiner gesagt um 17 uhr ist feierabend
oder sowas was an glückliche
zuversichtliche leute unternehmer die
nicht darauf gewartet haben dass sie
irgend eine staatliche förderung
bekommen haben sondern man spürte den
willen das schicksal selbst in die hand
zu nehmen und und ich wollte euch von
dieser geisteshaltung erzählen ja es ist
ja häufig so dass
von kapitalismuskritikern ja das
unternehmertum als eine art ökonomisch
kapitalistische beschäftigung betätigung
heruntergeredet wird natürlich noch mit
dem mit ungerechten ziel der
profitmaximierung
da war nix mit brasilien gedanken da war
leidenschaft da war diese geisteshaltung
diese lebenseinstellung ja
unternehmertum als als eine art
lebensform ja und da habe ich mir
gedacht war das ist eine gute nachricht
was es hier stattfindet aber auch noch
tausendmal sonst in deutschland wir
haben tausende von jungen unternehmen
wir haben so viele chancen für gründer
wie noch nie in der geschichte durch die
ganze digitalisierung und das unterdorf
internet und um dieses deutschland das
möchte ich sehen darüber will ich
diskutieren mit dieser mentalität werden
die ein aufstiegs land und mit der
mentalität bei diesem training gesehen
haben wo zwei drittel der sendezeit nur
über hartz iv und über höheren steuern
und über bedenkenträger turm diskutiert
wurde das ist das rezept für ein
abstiegs land da sind wir doch wir haben
wir genau das erlebt was ich anziehen
neulich begleitet habe
leidenschaft und ihr seid blut trinker
nicht mehr so eine begeisterung gespürt
er über den aber das ist doch etwas was
man was man offensichtlich auch in einer
in einer unternehmenskultur finden kann
begeisterung für ein produkt für das
engagement und das ist tatsächlich uns
ist die begeisterung ein bisschen
verloren gegangen in diesem land und was
jedoch sagen so etwas jedoch sagen
wollte und und
gegenteil dazu ich ja diese geradezu
wuchernde staatsgläubigkeit ich rede ja
schon von starts förmlichkeit wenn du
der staat soll möglichst viele dinge
regeln nein das soll nicht wir brauchen
keinen größeren staat wir brauchen einen
effizienten staat und dann müssen wir
den mut haben und die risikobereitschaft
den leuten denn denn mit
eigenverantwortung mit
risikobereitschaft
einfach zuzutrauen dass die bessere
lösungen finden als die beamten und die
staatssekretäre im staatsapparat ich
finde georg thomas da einen wichtigen
punkt weil es geht manchmal gar nicht so
um politische fragen ob wir die republik
mehr links oder rechts und liberal rom
stecken sondern auch um haltungen
umstimmen und dieses was du da gerade
ausdrückt ich erinnere mich an meinem
allerersten tag an der börse frankfurt
ich war jung ein reporter der faz und
wieder hin und alle waren euphorische
stimmung und ich sage gar keinen großen
anlass und dafür seien optimistisch in
den hessischen personelle warum sind sie
eigentlich so gut gelaunter sagte wissen
sie der pessimist ist der mist auf dem
nichts wächst und wir sind ja keine
pessimisten unternehmer sind von natur
aus eher optimisten sonst würden ja gar
nicht investieren und ins risiko gehen
und thomas man hat das ja mit seinen
buddenbrooks auch schön geschrieben also
die erste generation die etwas aufbaut
die so beschrieb er das die ist verliebt
ins gelingen und diese halten um das man
verliebt ist das etwas gelingen aus der
airbags in der regel etwas positives und
das ist so ein schöner kontrast zu den
kritikern und zu den malern zu den angst
machen und zudem verbiete aber das so zu
sagen ich wahrnehmen dass alle die
irgendwie in deutschland in einem
politischen amt in der verantwortung
stehen bauen sich für einen vorschlag
schon die hintertür ein falls er nicht
durchsetzbar ist durch die sie dann
verschwinden grünen laden muss das
glaube ich ist eines der großen probleme
dass diese hundertprozentige
begeisterung für etwas
gedimmt wird durch falls es nicht klappt
muss ich ja irgendwie dann auch noch
weiter in diesem politischen raum sein
denn ich glaube diese deutschland als
abstiegs land und diese mangelnde
begeisterung lebt ja ein berufsstand vor
das sind politiker also ich habe lang
ein wirklich selbst begeisternden
entweder selbst begeisterten von sich
selbst begeistert oskar lafontaine man
muss erst mal von sich selbst begeistert
sein dass man andere für sich begeistern
kann die wirklich mit passion für etwas
eintreten was wir für wichtig halten und
wenn es nicht durchsetzbar ist trotzdem
weiter dran glauben und neuen versuch
unternehmen und in zwei jahren wieder
das ist ja das weg aber das ist genau
doch das problem das uns das hinbekommen
erklärt uns ja die politiker sagen das
sind prozesse das sind langwierige
prozesse der demokratie wo die geglaubt
werden die man dann diskutiert und die
sich dann erledigen und das ist ja das
problem also wenn wir wenn wir die
chinesen bauen flughafen in vier monaten
die amerikaner haben alex habe ich
gesehen irgendwie in 22 jahren an die da
ein ding hingestellt ich konnte gar
nicht begreifen weil man eben das
deutsche tempo gewohntes aber das ist
offensichtlich einerseits sagt man uns
das muss so sein damit jeder seine
bedenkenlos werden kann andererseits
gibt es so viele bedenkenträger das
alles ja irgendwo letzten endes dann im
sand im getriebe hat wobei das war nicht
immer so also wenn man in die geschichte
gucken ludwig erhard hat wahlkämpfe
gewonnen mit dem mit dem spruch
wohlstand für alle ist jan poser
wohlstand für alle oder willy brandt
mehr demokratie wagen ist auch ein
positiver aspekt ich glaube dass in
diesem jahr diese etwas depressive
wahlkampfrhetorik auch darin begründet
ist dass wir noch im ausgang der
pandemie sind das ist im hinterkopf der
politiker war und wir dürfen hier keine
falschen prognosen keine falschen ort
sind doch alle gut gefahren mit der
angst und sicherheits methode ich möchte
nicht die der miesepeter der hunde sein
und ich finde das so bleibe brauchen
leid schon verbrauchen unternehmertum
mir ist die wirtschaft ja viel näher als
die politik im jahr wäre dass die
wirtschaft der motor ist die politik die
rahmenbedingungen aber was mich
mittlerweile einsetzt ist super viele
studenten brechen gerade ihr studium ab
weiß ist im home-office nicht mehr
durchhalten nach anderthalb jahren
wir gehen einen ausbildung ausbildung
sind auch ganz toll aber ich habe zum
beispiel letztens ein mädchen 1,9 abi
wollte immer ins bankwesen finance
angefangen eineinhalb jahren abgebrochen
macht jetzt eine ausbildung als
steuerfachangestellte was auch sehr gut
ist aber ich habe trotzdem das gefühl
dass wir die korona pandemie darunter an
die träume von jungen leute dagegen
gegen den an seinen hut es war noch nie
so viele junge leute an der aktie an der
börse alten wie er den unter 25 jährigen
ging zu hunderttausenden an die börse
das hat auch was mit jamie fiction zu
tun und angel und spekulation aber die
lust einer jungen generation sich dem
der wirtschaftlichen aktivität dem
erfolg und neuen dingen zu sagen die ist
gigantisch erstaunen das ist zum ersten
mal unter weiß ich genau wer in aktien
haben sich über 60 da gab es noch nie
aber ich glaube trotzdem dass wenn wir
die leidenschaft weitergeben wollen an
die jungen generation dass es endlich zu
ende sein muss ist muss man ja
präsenzunterricht an den
diese wird auf dauer finde ich
überhaupt nicht das vierte repression
viele leute hätten die decke laufen
kommt aber aber die leute sind soziale
wesen sie müssen sich nicht treffen
können habe aber gerade du mit einer
überbordenden energie das ist doch nicht
das bild das ich von vielen jugendlichen
habe die von work life balance schwärmen
na ja ich will aber erst mal ich will
gerne arbeiten aber erstmalig zwei
monate zu hause bleiben und möchte mich
um kindfrau und mutige kümmern was auch
immer
elternzeit oder ja es gibt 1000 tausend
gründe ist nicht mehr so wie du denkst
ich heiße eben nicht jetzt aber auch
andere
klavier üben und ja du hast ja alles
selbst aufgebaut das muss man ja auch
sagen du hast ja alles aber aus eigener
kraft auch gross geschafft mir absolut
null mit 0 welt und 0 40 jahren immer
wichtig weil viele denken ja ach der hat
ihn bestimmt ganz viele kontakte von
deinem südtiroler bergdorf damals war
einwohnern ja und ich bin der einzige
der da in die welt hinaus ist das
regulierte und außerdem ist nicht alles
geklärt du hast ja auch da die und eine
blutige nase geholt aber im nachhinein
sagen da mach ich oder hat aber
vielleicht das glück gehabt dafür
übersieht dass sich das vielleicht fünf
mal probiert habe und um drei mal
geschieht ja und diese diese diese
risikobereitschaft
und die lust also ich finde das den
ausdruck wunderbar die freude am
gelingen oder sondern verliebt sein ins
gelingen verliebt sein was zu gestalten
fand sein verliebt so etwas neues zu
schaffen verenden veränderungsbereit
sein risiko bereit sein das ist ja
politik wir brauchen diese leidenschaft
glaub ich geh ja ja
ja
ich habe ja für die fdp gespendet und
wissen warum wir haben alle über die
politiker hier so gesprochen dass die
daten bedenkenträgern schon vergangen
ich finde ich finde das team um
christian lindner plus ihre
vorstellungen die sind nicht so bedenke
der gast die sind mutig die sind klar
formuliert
die sind die sind
hier prägnant vorgetragen und und die
suggerieren schon freunde mit mut bringt
machst du was ja und mitleidet und
bringt machst du weißt was tipps zu und
setzen damit wäre die fdp kriegen und
deswegen ist der fdp bei der jüngeren
generation ja sie haben uns gedacht die
nummer zwei er ist die nummer zwei ja
und was ich tippe ja was auf ich hoffe
dass sie nahe an die grünen rankommen
hat ja auch also irgendwo zwischen 13
und 15 prozent
du bist habe investiert hoffe dass das
was wird
verliebt ins gelingen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]